[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de Paf
qui va être essentiellement politique
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de sujets
abordés pour en parler Véronique Jérôme
bonjour
de de quoi Paris saclaine Paris sacré
bonjour Patrice vous êtes avocate au
barreau de
commencer les phrases depuis les gens
qui les finition
merci beaucoup d'être ici vous étiez
vous avez été candidat au législatives
pour la nupesse dans la première
circonscription des Yvelines il y a deux
candidats d'ailleurs n'est pas ce qui
ont été élus
locatif dans ce département
et puis vous êtes conseiller municipal
de Guyancourt et Jean-Charles la joie
dit bonjour vous êtes éditeur
alors il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
choses dont on va parler peut-être qu'on
peut commencer par un petit round-up sur
l'actualité un peu avec des points un
peu rapides sur lesquels on peut on peut
s'interroger donc les questions d'actu
pour commencer
[Musique]
vous êtes assez d'accord avec ça
je pense que globalement ce débat là qui
arrive là maintenant alors que il y a
une crise de l'inflation que les gens
ont du mal à remplir leur frigo qui a
une réforme des retraites et une crise
sociale inédite je pense que dans une
tranche par d'autres choses dans une
niche parlementaire on aurait peut-être
pu penser à autre chose et à d'autres
priorités on a fait jeudi dernier il y a
eu la liste parlementaire elle est fille
communiste à l'Assemblée nationale il y
avait la nationalisation d'EDF il y
avait des amendements qui permettaient
d'encadrer les charges locatives et
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie
donc peut-être que dans une niche
parlementaire le groupe modem aurait pu
mettre quelque chose d'autre de plus
intéressant
des bruits de retour de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est que y compris dans les
rangs de la macronie et de la droite
personne comprend ce que ce texte vient
faire là c'est pas une priorité il y a
des gens qui sont pour des gens qui sont
contre ces mêmes il y a même pas de
clivage en tant que tel de partie
moi je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
nécessaire
et puis si on veut faire aimer l'Union
européenne aux gens je pense que le
meilleur moyen de faire ça c'est que
cette institution soit véritablement
démocratique et qu'elle soit réformée et
que aujourd'hui il y a une symbolique
derrière tout ça quand même c'est qu'on
a on perd de plus en plus de
souveraineté nationale face à une
souveraineté qui elle encore une fois et
contestable en termes démocratique au
niveau européen et donc je pense que ça
va juste renforcer certains nombreux
ressentiments vis-à-vis de ces
institutions
qui a très peu de compétences comme vous
le savez l'essentiel des décisions
l'essentiel de textes sont faits au
niveau de la Commission européenne ce
sont des gens qui sont mandatés par les
différents pays qui composent le Conseil
européen et donc globalement c'est des
gens non élus qui mettent en place des
directives et qui propose au peuple et
je prends la plus connue celle des 3%,
vous savez les fameuses règles de
déficit imposer au niveau presque
constitutionnel bon bah ça c'est un
problème dans la capacité des pays à
souverain sur leur budget et à faire
leur propre décision et leur propre
choix c'est une règle économique
économique qui n'a ni que ni tête ni
justification et qui s'impose à toutes
et tous et qui justifient des réformes
comme la réforme des retraites qui est
profondément injuste et
inutile si ça pose mais qui n'est pas
respecté
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu la crise du
covid qui a changé un peu de choses mais
la France prend quand même peut prendre
ses aises on parle de to Bic to fait
trop importante pour laisser tomber pour
qu'on la laisse tomber et la France a
longtemps utilisé un peu cet état
d'esprit de dire on est tellement
important dans l'Europe que si on est
défaillant c'est pas possible c'est
possible pour nous ni pour les autres
donc on prend un peu et entre
parenthèses de cette contrainte des
critères de Maastricht ne rentrera à
nouveau en vigueur que l'année prochaine
est préalablement peut-être à une au
préalablement ça il y aura une
discussion pour savoir si on va les
laisser dans ce dans ces termes donc
pour l'instant c'est mis un peu en
sommeil il y a l'obligation et même plus
constitutionnelles n'est pas
constitutionnelle par contre juste une
parenthèse on pourrait dans la
Constitution mettre une règle d'or et
imposer de ne pas faire de déficit et
demander à l'État d'équilibrer
certains le font donc ça on pourrait
discuter mais pour l'instant c'est une
règle effectivement c'est quelque chose
qui a été fait sur un coin de table
fallait bien donner
l'historique des 3% en effet c'est un
truc comme ça qui était sorti un peu du
chapeau
voilà
et pourquoi pas deux et pourquoi pas
l'équilibre et c'est vrai que la
rationalité économique commanderait
qu'on soit l'équipe
de de Marion Aubry maintenant au prix
pardon il y a il y a il y a en effet
un enjeu politique c'est vrai que
vos partenaires de de ELV sont étranglés
quand elle a parlé de vos futurs
démocratique parce que leur ADN c'est
quand même la construction européenne et
dire que l'Europe est une forte
démocratique pour les pour les écolos
c'est c'est
il n'entendable
un programme commun elle est finie lui
pèse pour la présidentielle et sur
l'Europe on a réussi à se mettre
d'accord sur un certain nombre de points
LFI n'est pas anti-européen loin de là
déjà parce que l'espace européen c'est
avant tout un espace géographique où il
y a une libre circulation des gens donc
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on défend et
on va pas s'extirper géographiquement de
l'Europe c'est pas l'ordre du jour donc
on est dedans l'Union européenne la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
comment on la change nous on n'est pas
opposé l'Europe on est opposé à 7 Europe
là qui s'impose au peuple et qui prend
des décisions qui ne vont pas dans le
sens de la souveraineté nationale et de
l'intérêt général
là-dessus
pour revenir au drapeau et pas au
programme politique de notre famille
assez attaché au drapeau français même
très attaché donc je trouve que ça c'est
bien que ce soit le drapeau français
pour autre chose qu'on peut avoir aux
couleurs européennes de temps en temps
pourquoi pas après on s'est peut-être la
première fois que les dernières je serai
d'accord avec les films est-ce que
c'était vraiment le moment je suis pas
sûr effectivement c'est peut-être il y a
peut-être une façon de dériver un peu
des problèmes actuels mais pourquoi mais
après tout c'était le 9 mai c'est le
Journée de l'Europe c'est pas quand le
président de la République intervient
d'ailleurs je crois que le drapeau
européen toujours maintenant
pourquoi pas
alors moi je suis je suis plutôt pour je
j'entends et je suis assez d'accord sur
le fait que c'était peut-être pas le
moment mais pour autant l'Europe a été
constituée pour pouvoir avoir une Europe
et une zone géographique de paix
et là on a la guerre à nos frontières et
donc c'est totalement
anormal d'avoir le drapeau européen pour
l'Europe étant aux côtés de l'Ukraine et
donc moi je pense que c'est plutôt une
bonne chose d'avoir l'Europe la France
fait partie de l'Europe c'est quelque
chose qui doit se à mon sens se
renforcer plus d'harmonie avoir plus
d'harmonie que ce soit l'harmonie
fiscale que ce soit l'harmonie sociale
donc il y a un gros travail à faire pour
faire évoluer l'Europe sur ce terrain là
mais je pense que c'est franchement une
un
pôle de de nations qui doivent
œuvrer dans le même sens et devenir
économiquement socialement fort donc moi
je suis plutôt pour
fréquemment s'intéresser à l'Europe de
la
défenseur
magnifique on est 500 millions
d'Européens on a un porte-avion c'est le
porte-avion français et tous les
États-Unis sont 320 millions en ont 12
un des Chinois en construisent deux
parents
justement
et l'enjeu c'est de c'est de la
renforcer sur plan de la défense
maintenant ça c'est probablement une
volonté française mais quand on voit
l'obstruction permanente des Allemands à
toutes velléité de faire quoi que ce
soit en matière de défense avec la
France
aux États-Unis ça n'a pas changé c'est
des vœux pieux on passe
on va faire un peu de people oui
Brigitte Bardot qui est
une saga qui raconte sa vie
qui est
son mari toujours au RN non il était
toujours marié je sais pas c'est pour ça
la question
mais vous avez regardé ça vous intéresse
c'est un symbole c'est de quelque chose
ou pas en tout cas la comédienne est
charmante et je trouve que c'est plutôt
bien choisi en tout cas physiquement
comme ça je
sur le reste je sais pas
oui après c'est très bien de faire un
truc autour de Brigitte Bardot c'est
comme quelqu'un qui a beaucoup compté
qui a une carrière exceptionnelle enfin
bon après il y a sûrement noté plein de
gens après où il y a plein de gens qui
vont écrire l'histoire qui vont la
traiter tous les noms donc c'est une
image de la femme absolument caricatura
bon comme on réécrit tout en ce moment
et tout le monde applaudit dès demain
bientôt on va peut-être brûler les
effigies de de Bardot elle a été un
moment c'était une Marianne je pense
qu'il y a des gens qui ont vouloir
des quelques Mariannes représentés voilà
mais c'est ce qui s'est passé
pas du tout pour ça mais c'est pour ça
que je trouve bien et puis que les gens
un peu plus jeune que nous puissent
avoir une vision de ce qui a été
Brigitte Bardot c'est quand même tout à
fait intéressant
sur Brigitte Bardot sur la liberté de
Brigitte Bardot pourtant Simone de
Beauvoir
quand elle veut comme elle veut et une
grande liberté féminine mais
après je regarderai pas la série
regarder parce que par curiosité je
trouvais que alors j'avais vu quelques
critiques préalablement et il est vrai
que Daniel Thompson a vraiment essayé de
retranscrire à demander à l'actrice la
ressemblance personnellement j'ai pas
été convaincue mais peut-être que les
épisodes suivants le seront j'ai vu
juste le début mais simplement Bardot a
marqué son son époque je pense que elle
a peut-être plus vécu le féminisme
qu'elle ne l'a transmis ou transcrit etc
donc elle a fait de sa vie
une vie de de femmes libres elle a
arrêté sa carrière en pleine gloire en
73 donc ça on peut lui reconnaître au
moins de ne pas faire ce que font
certaines actrices qui essayent de
s'accrocher
ensuite une cause et la cause animale et
a fait pression sur tous les présidents
de la République quel qu'il soit en
avance
voilà les les bébés phoques enfin des
images de bébé phoques donc c'est un
combat qui était avec son importance il
faudrait pas oublier derrière le
personnage qui qui est une actrice et
qui a après une pleine des plaies je
pense que mais je pense qu'elle a plus
servi à cause de la femme qu'elle ne la
desservie me semble-t-il vous avez un
mot non j'ai pas d'avis sur
la question je pense que vous projetez
beaucoup de crainte et de quand je vous
écoute parler j'ai l'impression que tout
est en train de s'effondrer
je trouve que au contraire bon ben on
fait des films sur des personnes qui ont
marqué notre histoire l'histoire du
cinéma français donc moi ça a rien qui
me surprend en dehors du fait que
évidemment la des prises de position
assez proche de l'extrême droite que
tout le monde connaît mais bon voilà moi
je regarderai pas personnellement la
série ça m'intéresse pas plus que ça
est-ce que vous avez regardé le
couronnement de faire le 3
Elisabeth quelque chose de très désuet
et de très dépassé mais
sentiment après tout franchement je
trouve pas que ce soit dépassé est-ce
que on peut on peut le débattre de
l'utilité ou pas d'avoir une monarchie
ou pas à partir du moment où on accepte
il détient un roi qui est toute la pompe
qui tourne autour du haut de la reine me
paraît tout à fait normal alors il y a
des gens qui osent parler de déguisement
tout ça parce que il y a des choses
en quoi ce sera un déguisement alors
c'est quasiment un uniforme uniforme de
roi il y a des militants des uniformes
les prélats ont des uniformes je vois
pas je vois pas en quoi on peut se
moquer de ça et puis ensuite je trouve
que en France on a un côté vraiment
aigri et assez lamentable c'est à dire
que c'est une affaire qui concerne
essentiellement les Anglais et et on est
là à critiquer comme si ça se passait
chez nous à Montreuil ah bah non je veux
dire c'est pas là je veux dire peu
importe qui se débrouille et qu'il fasse
qu'ils veulent les Anglais
ont passé trois jours visiblement
il y avait de savoir s'il faut garder ou
quoi mais voilà le problème
qui se permettait de dire oui ben il
faudra bientôt que ça change et cetera
enfin je veux dire c'est on est juste
dans l'aberration totale enfin on est
quand même alors c'est ça qui peut
choquer aujourd'hui c'est à dire que il
y a des gens qui ne sont pas égaux aux
autres de par leur naissance c'est ça la
monarchie quand même est-ce que ça c'est
admissible aujourd'hui ou pas c'est un
problème qui peut se poser
une question qui peut se poser tout à
fait admissible parce que de toute façon
c'est la réalité je veux dire oui
exactement alors après on se focalise
sur le monarchie la démocratie c'est
c'est le contraire de ça quand même
c'est de te dire tout le monde est-ce
que Luffy est-ce que le fils de Bolloré
est pareil est né comme les autres
est-ce que le fils de Bernard Arnault
est né comme les autres non
déjà quand même plus de chance donc
voilà on peut pas lutter contre l'ordre
des choses c'est c'est un milliardaire
qui qui déshérite leurs enfants pour
justement leur donner
en France on n'a pas le droit de toute
façon les milliardaires qui déshéritent
aux États-Unis ils déshérite d'à peu
près
c'est 70 % de leur fortune alors la
fortune de Bill Gates quand il en reste
30 %
franchement
deuxième fois qu'on est d'accord sur ce
plateau vous saignez quelque chose de
parfaitement juste c'est que la
République c'est elle est indissociable
de la République sociale c'est-à-dire
que les citoyens ne peuvent pas naître
libre et égaux en droit et exercer cette
liberté s'il y a justement une inégalité
qui est profonde à partir de la
naissance donc effectivement quand on
critique le régiment anglais on critique
avant tout c'est accumulation de
richesse qui fait que le Royaume-Uni est
un des pays les plus inégalitaires
d'Europe que aujourd'hui le roi a des
possessions de terre qui se une dizaine
de milliards d'euros et que le citoyen
anglais peut rien y faire c'est setter
et il est obligé de verser un impôt à
quelqu'un qui n'a ni été élu qui est
juste né comme ça et qu'il aurait pas et
en fait c'est tout à fait comparable
effectivement au Bolloré et compagnie
parce que voilà on est dans un système
d'accumulation
et de naissance de
réparer ça avec l'impôt avec la
redistribution des richesses avec eux
économiquement la royauté la monarchie
anglaise
rapporte beaucoup plus qu'elle le coûte
le couronnement par exemple on parle on
parle de d'à peu près suivant les
estimations suivant les journaux entre
50 et 120 millions d'euros dépensés et
ça va rapporter plus de plusieurs
milliards d'euros
parce que
vont être pris sur les impôts des
Anglais mais est-ce que c'est milliards
vont être distribués aux Anglais qu'on
payait des impôts bien sûr
un chiffre précis en matière de tourisme
la famille royale royale rapporte 2
milliards par an 2 milliards d'euros
c'est pas rien et là ça va être beaucoup
plus
représente pour poursuivre là-dessus le
roi représente en fait l'unité pour les
Anglais le roi représente l'unité du
Royaume-Uni et il est au-dessus de
ça
un peu mais pour les Anglais
politiquement ça permet aussi sans doute
ça permet sans aucun doute aux Anglais
de mieux supporter les changements
politiques de premier ministre parce que
il y a justement le roi au-dessus et que
du coup il y a une certaine permanence
de l'état non mais je veux dire qu'il
reste là
et du coup c'est du coup c'est pas tous
les ans parce que qu'on soit Premier
ministre travailliste ou conservatoire
bon c'est pas une révolution à chaque
fois donc alors qu'en France on le voit
bien
une constitution on a une déclaration
des droits
de citoyen donc on a aussi un certain
nombre de textes une valeur qui se place
théoriquement au-dessus l'ensemble de
l'échiquier
parlementaire
jusqu'au brexit quand même qui a été
ça c'est les référendum
en fait
on peut juste sur l'image j'aurais juste
dire deux choses je ne suis pas sûr que
il le conserve toute l'affection du
peuple anglais que sa mère se ressentait
et puis son attitude c'est pour ça que
j'ai regardé mais ce revenu après j'ai
interrompu je suis revenu lors du
couronnement parce que l'attitude on
avait l'impression qu'il n'avait pas
envie d'être là qu'il était triste à
mourir alors que il attendait ça comme
depuis quelques années et il y avait pas
la solennité le côté serein dans le
visage qui s'exprimait il y a quand même
une je sais pas un manque d'empathie son
utile
avec quoi 23 ans je crois et qu'il en a
74 donc ça a pris un coup de vieux si je
peux non mais je pense pas que là j'ai
quelque chose je pense que ça joue quand
même couramment 53 c'était la fin de la
guerre il y avait comme ça une sorte de
légèreté dont on avait besoin
aujourd'hui c'est comme les
circonscients sont quand même très
différentes de la charge parce que on
s'en moque ou qu'on apprécie etc je veux
dire c'est quand même une cérémonie et
une une importance pour beaucoup de gens
qui qui fait sûrement peser beaucoup de
choses sur les épaules du du monarque
donc je comprends qu'il soit pas il a un
moment de de non non mais il y a un côté
je me sembler il me semblait décalé
votre discussion démontre bien que avant
tout la famille royale c'est une
histoire people c'est une histoire
people qui intéresse à peu près 70% des
personnes de plus de 50 ans là où 30 %
des jeunes en se disent soutiennent
activement la monarchie là où 70% sont à
opposés au maintien de
courant anti monarchie ça c'est fort
[Musique]
pour terminer sur ce random d'actualité
peut-être vous voulez parler d'un
tableau qui fait polémique au Palais de
Tokyo
le voilà enfin on le voit à peu près
oui alors c'est un tableau bon
effectivement on voit une personne comme
le disait Florence c'est peut-être un
géant avec une un autre une autre
personne de taille plus modeste
on peut quand même penser que c'est un
adulte et un enfant alors moi je suis
contre toute censure donc en matière
d'art donc ça ne me choque pas on n'est
pas obligé d'aller le voir la seule
chose qui pourrait être choquante
ça a été demandé alors ça a été demandé
par des associations de défense de
l'enfant et c'était demandé
effectivement par le rassemblement
national et le le type qui a badigeonné
cette peinture est un ancien membre du
rassemblement national voilà et elle
continuera d'être exposée telle qu'elle
est
tout ça le seul petit problème il y a
pas un véritable problème c'est que je
vois pas bien comment
l'artiste qui a peint ça peut nous dire
que c'est un truc la guerre voilà c'est
juste ça c'est moi je comprends qu'on
paye ce qu'on veut mais qu'on me dise
que ça c'est un tableau qui lutte contre
la guerre voilà j'ai un tout petit
slogan fait l'amour pas la guerre
mais bon après
sur là mais voilà après oui c'est vrai
que
enfin juridiquement d'ailleurs le
François pays de liberté la liberté de
l'art elle est voilà l'artiste elle
prime
sinon c'est la fin de tout parce que
l'art est un mode d'expression la
liberté d'expression la comme limite la
liberté des autres donc à partir du
moment où on nuit à l'intégrité physique
et morale à travers une oeuvre d'art à
d'autres personnes effectivement on peut
se poser la question d'une entre
guillemets censure mais qui est légitime
vous pourriez pas par exemple faire une
chanson glorifiant le nazisme en France
parce que justement il y a une limite
qui est fixée à la liberté d'expression
heureusement
je vois pas de je vois pas le moindre
signe nazi et si à ce moment-là si je
vous suis on va se balader au Louvre et
tout tout tableau représentant un
guerrier en train de trancher la tête
d'un autre devrait être supprimé parce
que c'est une vision offensante de la
vie et qui ne devrait pas représenter
heureusement il y a quand même des
historiens dans notre pays il y a quand
même des personnes qui étudient qui sont
capables de contextualiser les choses et
on peut toujours on peut pas extraire
tout de son contexte donc il me semble
que je connais pas le fond de cette
histoire là mais s'il y a des
associations qui ont émis des
oppositions à la présentation de cette
œuvre d'art voilà c'est comme ça le
procédé en fait en République on s'y
prend de cette manière là c'est que le
tribunal aroché leur demande voilà donc
cette juge qui est donc c'est pour ça
que moi je suis évidemment je soutiens
pas la dégradation d'une oeuvre d'art
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
ça peut être quelque chose de tout à
fait concevable de fixer les limites à
une liberté d'expression artistique
le droit n'est pas la moralité
apprend sa décision sur quelle base la
décision du respect des libertés donc il
se pose la question il s'interroge sur
est-ce que la liberté des expressions
encore une fois va à l'encontre de la
liberté de la dignité d'autres personnes
et c'est là-dessus mais il y avait dans
la morale
de la discrimination du racisme du
sexisme de
base là que l'État liberté d'expression
dans un livre on n'aurait pas le droit
non plus de raconter une histoire qui se
passe sur un tableau sur ce tableau
mais encore une fois le principe il y a
des lois il y a des juges il décide à la
fin l'état droit
il faut respecter la liberté des autres
après chacun a ses citoyens
chacun a sa propre sa propre vision de
de par exemple du tableau il y en a que
ça choque d'autres que ça choque pas ou
est-ce que vous mettez la limite pour
son support dire ah bah non bah là son
atteint la liberté d'un certain nombre
de personnes pas d'autres à quel moment
vous êtes quel critère vous allez mettre
et puis après si vous après vous allez
vous allez dériver sur plein de sujets
donc faut surtout pas après aller sur
des dérives qui peuvent être après des
dérives un peu totalitaires votre
liberté c'est d'aller voir le tableau ou
pas alors c'est tout la justice est
indépendante et elle doit être
correctement financée elle doit
fonctionner correctement donc moi je
suis pour l'État de droit et donc je
pense aussi à la liberté de circuler
d'avoir des opinions de vivre sa vie
pleinement et de s'émanciper de tout
citoyens qui peut être victime de
racisme encore une fois de
discrimination de celle-ci etc donc d'où
le
faites porno
je résume votre position vous dites
voilà il y a des lois on peut saisir le
juge et c'est tout juste ici donc
grossesse
après tout pourquoi pas
après de dire il faut une loi pour
le texte
et après voilà on peut penser que la
liberté de l'artiste est
en effet est absolu
dans les faits voilà
on peut représenter dans les hommes
régulièrement vous avez vu par exemple
récemment un débat alors je sais pas si
on peut la pleine artiste mais vous avez
une littéraire que vous connaissez bien
de Monsieur Hitler qui a été republié
Minecraft bon ben a eu lieu un débat
juridique et une décision du juge à la
fin qui a tranchée
[Musique]
un jeu de société qui parlait des Black
Blocs qui parlaient de des
manifestations de rue donc ils mettaient
ça en scène de manière humoristique il y
a eu juridique la justice a donné raison
en l'occurrence là au créateur du jeu de
plateau il a pu être
les Black Blocs mais si on fait un jeu
autour des plages
que ça pose question donc voilà pour moi
ça fait même pas de débat je m'en fous
si j'ai pas envie j'achète pas le jeu
avec les Black Blocs c'est tout mais
qu'on fasse déjà que les Black Bloc tant
mieux
si entre deux parties vous pouvez les
mettre en prison jusqu'à ravi mais
qu'on arrive enfin les arrêter plutôt
que de toute façon
on va passer à un autre sujet c'est la
deuxième décision du Conseil
constitutionnel rejetant le le
référendum d'initiative partagée bien
que le terme ne soit pas d'ailleurs
légal parle de proposition de loi mais
pas de référendum dans le dans la loi
mais enfin bon le rip est à la trappe
quoi le il y aura pas de référendum
[Musique]
alors c'était c'était une demande des
sénateurs de gauche
qui avait été faite par le
passé sénateur et aux conseiller
constitutionnel demandant un référendum
d'initiative partagée on ne le dit
parfois des populaires aussi
demandons que le l'âge de l'égal de la
retraite ne puisse pas dépasser 62 ans
et pour la deuxième fois le
Constitutionnel rejeté la décision sur
une argumentation relativement simple
c'est à dire que la loi qui s'applique
actuellement prévoit la retraite Las
Vegas à 62 ans donc
si on veut un référendum il faut que ça
soit une réforme et le Conseil
constitutionnel a constaté que passer à
soi de 62 ans à 62 ans ne constituez pas
une réforme en gros c'est ça
l'argumentation je comprends pas
pourquoi la question n'était pas vous
pour ou contre une retraite à 64 ans
il faut que ça soit il faut que il faut
que le projet de référendum le
proposition de loi soit une profession
de réforme d'une loi actuelle et bon
Sébastien il y a une petite confusion à
votre présentation donc ça c'était le
motif de rejet du premier
le deuxième référendum d'initiative je
suis partagé justement les gens étaient
très surpris qui ne passent pas parce
que partant de cet argument on aurait pu
considérer qu'à partir du moment où la
vouloir a été votée à l'Assemblée
nationale etc age a été décalé à 64 ans
si le Conseil constitutionnel avait star
argument là pour le premier rejet il
accepterait la deuxième et en fait le
motif de rejet c'est que pour financer
parce qu'il faut financer une réforme a
été créée un impôt sur le capital pour
permettre ce passage à à nouveau à 62
ans et c'est sûr ces motifs là que le
Conseil constitutionnel est rejeté donc
preuve que cet organe si il y a
évidemment une question légale et
juridique c'est avant tout une question
politique qui fait qu'il y avait en
effet un aspect de malheureusement qui
permettait de maintenir le système de
retraite par répartition dans le dans la
profession dans la proposition de loi
des sénateurs de gauche mais le problème
c'est pas considéré comme une réforme et
là quand on fouille un peu c'est amusant
sur la généalogie de ce référendum
d'initiative partagé on s'aperçoit qu'en
fait il était mis en place en 2008 dans
la réforme de 2008 voulue par Nicolas
Sarkozy pour s'attirer un certain nombre
de votes de centrist ou de centrices de
gauche mais que il a été fait de telle
façon que ce référendum ne puisse jamais
avoir lieu en gros
peut-être heureusement tant mieux tant
mieux c'est une aberration démocratique
on est dans un régime où on a
suffisamment d'élus on a des députés qui
votent et
législature ils sont virés où ils sont
reconduits et voilà il y a pas besoin de
redonner la parole comme ça sur des
sujets enfin je veux dire
abracad gigantesque et je veux dire
c'est une perte de temps
anti-anti démocratique au possible voilà
je veux bien que c'est très à la mode de
dire le pouvoir est dans la rue on
manifeste on brûle des poubelles donc on
a raison donc le peuple est là et de
remettre en question systématiquement le
résultat des élections c'est un
tropisme de certains partis politiques
ben moi c'est pas le mien et je veux
dire tant mieux qu'il y ait pas de de
référendum et que ce soit définitivement
enterré peut-être qu'un jour il y a
quelqu'un qui a on arrête avec cette
cette chimère en fait vous reprenez un
peu ce que ce que ce que dit Dominique
crédit que le président de fond d'Apple
qui est Sciences Po qui dit au fond
lui dit selon lui qu'il faut faire
attention aux RIP parce que ce serait
une façon donnée aux populistes je le
cite de dire qu'on peut défaire par la
rue ce que les parlementaires ont fait
c'est exactement ça
vous êtes toujours dans la modération en
tout cas dans vos propos
[Musique]
en l'occurrence là sur le rip c'est pas
juste une demande de notre partie c'est
une demande de l'ensemble des parties de
gauche au scénario nationale et surtout
c'est une demande des organisations
syndicales dans notre pays l'intégralité
alors vous êtes peut-être contre le
principe d'organisation syndicale mais
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
de notre pays demandez à ce que ce RIP
puisse passer pour qu'on passe justement
pour qu'on résout un conflit qui était
bloqué d'un point de vue institutionnel
en ayant la seule voie de recours c'est
à dire celle des urnes donc affirmer que
c'est un manque de démocratie de
consulter le peuple moi ça me paraît
compliqué d'autant plus que je vais vous
parler des élections législatives là en
l'occurrence le texte n'a pas été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale justement parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de majorité pour le
porter donc le seul outil qui a été
trouvé pour le faire placer c'est le
49-3 donc 49 3 c'est hyper démocratique
donc les députés en l'occurrence retirer
le droit de vote pour faire un passage
en force
quel est le truc démocratique par
essence c'est-à-dire que les députés
avaient la possibilité de faire sauter
le gouvernement ils ne l'ont pas fait
c'est donc démocratique ils ont choisi
il y a eu plus de voix pour soutenir
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai que cette idée que le
49-3 c'est un déni de démocratie elle
est quand même un peu bizarre c'était un
article de la Constitution qui a été
utilisé une centaine de fois depuis le
début de la cinquième République
notamment dans le site toujours par
Michel regard parce qu'il est pas non
plus de majorité absolue dont on peut
pas dire que c'est la figure type du
dictateur quand même c'est pas
comparable il y avait pas des millions
de personnes dans la rue des millions de
grévistes au moment où Michel Rocard
utilise le 49.3 il y a quand même une
différence de contexte alors vous disiez
c'est pas la rue puis fait la loi quand
même la rue la rue dans une démocratie
il y a des pays où les gens ne peuvent
pas descendre dans la rue Russie etc
de la génération des jeunes etc je veux
dire si les jeunes allaient voter au
lieu de manifester ce serait déjà pas
mal on les voit pas dans les bureaux de
vote on les voit vont dire des panneaux
alors ça c'est très bien mais sont-ils
dans les départements
et tout à fait agréable et
j'en suis ravi parce que vous êtes mais
vous êtes un peu seul
s'ils allaient voter peut-être ça
changerait les choses sur sur la
gouvernance de la France
alors déjà c'est pas trop facile de
revenir une pancarte faire grève
manifester une dizaine de fois c'est un
engagement qui est important il y a des
jeunes qui mettent de côté leurs études
pour faire ça il y a des gens qui
mettent de côté leur salaire pour faire
ça donc prenons ne prenons pas la légère
l'engagement de plusieurs millions de
nos concitoyens qui sont s'exprimer dans
la rue et écoutons la revendication
c'est la moindre des choses qu'on peut
faire dans une démocratie et quand on
compare
les régimes autoritaires justement à une
démocratie la grande différence c'est
que justement entre deux élections alors
dans les régimes autoritaires à son
trafiqués évidemment et entre deux
élections il y a des temps aussi de
respiration démocratique qui sont des
temps de mobilisation populaire et qui
sont écoutées par par les gouvernements
que nous sommes bien dans une démocratie
moi j'ai jamais dit le contraire n'ayant
simplement une démocratie elle peut être
améliorée elle peut être changer et je
pense que Voilà la démocratie ne se
limite pas aux élections législatives et
présidentielles il y a des
contre-pouvoirs entre temps il y a 12
millions de salariés qui sont appelés
aux ions de chaque année pour élire des
représentants syndicaux qui eux aussi
sont élus démocratiquement et qu'il
s'agit d'écouter donc les
contre-pouvoirs les élections
intermédiaires et les référendum tout ça
on va parler justement parce que ça
c'est sur un peu la partie sur la
conception du peuple puisqu'on va voir
qu'il y a une opposition entre le peuple
qui conteste et puis la autorité
silencieuse on sait jamais où est le
will pop mais pour en venir un duo sur
le sur le référendum oui évidemment
consulter le peuple c'est c'est
démocratique mais on voit bien qu'à
chaque fois que le référendum a été
utilisé soit il a été utilisé par de
Gaulle comme un plébiscite c'est moi ou
le chaos et voilà c'est pour voter pour
moi ou contre moi et du coup à chaque
fois qu'il y a un référendum bah on a
tout intérêt à voter contre celui qui
pose la question c'est à dire que c'est
pour ça que les aucun président de la
République depuis
le quinquennat Chirac quoi
et depuis le vote contre la Constitution
européenne n'ose utiliser la procédure
afin est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce que
c'est pas un peu vicié quoi ce
référendum en français ce qu'il faudrait
pas faire des référendums un peu
dépassionnés où il y aurait pas d'enjeu
politique c'est-à-dire il y aurait pas
la démission au bout là où la remise en
cause de la légitimité de de de pouvoir
en place là peut-être que ça je suis
très d'accord avec ce que avec ce que
vous dites par exemple en Suisse ça
fonctionne très bien les référendum mais
il faut une question simple c'est à dire
par exemple êtes-vous pour ou contre la
peine de mort
non mais simple je veux dire le débat
est important mais c'est oui non enfin
c'est ça c'est pas c'est compliqué de
répondre par lui non ce genre de
question sur la peine de mort bah si
peut-être
oui mais ça dépend si on veut dire oui
pour
les morales systématiquement
voilà
la réponse est oui non et donc il y a
des référendums qui pourraient être mis
en place alors là c'est particulier
parce que c'est à la suite à la suite
d'une loi qui est contestée qui a été
voilà mais je pense que moi j'ai assez
debout
le dernier référendum qui a eu en France
c'était pour ou contre
Notre-Dame-des-Landes les gens
massivement
les gens massivement voté pour
l'aérodrome enfin l'aéroport pardon et
le président
le résultat n'est pas tout à fait
conforme à ce qu'on veut donc on en
tient pas compte vous voulez pas c'était
que c'était difficilement applicable
peut-être pas poser la question j'en
sais rien mais c'est un petit peu
qui était au gouvernement à l'époque
était plutôt à l'aéroport donc c'est un
peu comme le
sur la question vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est ça dépasse les enjeux de
la simple question qu'on pose parce que
on juge celui qui l'a posé notamment
enfin et est-ce qu'il faudrait pas oui
trouver parce que d'une procédure
importante et intéressante de consulter
le peuple mais ce qu'il faudrait pas
trouver une matière un peu plus dépassée
de le poser c'est à dire de ne pas y
mettre autant de dangereux politique que
vous le faites par exemple c'est marrant
que vous appliquez sur un raisonnement
au référendum et pas aux 49-3 justement
le principe du 49 3D je reviens sur un
débat précédent c'est que justement vous
changez l'enjeu du scrutin et vous
retirez l'enjeu principal qui est la
question de la retraite donc évidemment
pour un député c'est pas la même chose
de voter la démission du gouvernement et
de voter la retraite à 62 ou à 64 ans
sur la question du référendum si vous en
retirez le contenu politique et plus
aucun intérêt à faire un référendum tout
l'intérêt
politique on retiré tout ce qui est
autour de ce contenu politique c'est à
dire les les il va de soi
le gouvernement il cherche un tel ou
telle hypothèse donc il engage aussi sa
responsabilité politique quand il fait
un référendum
qui a été élu et réélu n'est pas
légitime bon il y a quand même été des
luttes de quoi mais alors si en plus il
fait un référendum et qu'il perd
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous allez
dire déjà on dit pas qu'il est pas
légitime point il est pas légitime à
faire un certain nombre de réformes
une petite nuance et
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire
[Musique]
forcément ça a des enjeux politiques
quoi oui bah donc et donc
la démocratie justement c'est que quand
il y a une situation de blocage ou même
des violences c'est la manière
institutionnelle de résoudre les
conflits et les débats de la société à
travers une méthode qui est tout à fait
Pacifique c'est-à-dire aller aux urnes
mettre un papier dans dans une boîte et
c'est comme ça qu'on résout les conflits
en détruit bien sûr parce que très
honnêtement vous accepteriez le résultat
des référendum vous remettez en cause
systématiquement toutes les élections
mais là un référendum si vous perdiez le
référendum vous seriez dans la rue en
train de dire on arrête tout plus de
grève plus rien alors vu les sondages il
y a peu de chance
honnêtement mais est-ce que vous seriez
prêt à accepter de perdre un référence
qui a une difficulté ces derniers mois
dans les débats publics c'est que à
chaque fois qu'on est en désaccord avec
une décision futelle démocratique on est
traité au final d'antirer-publicains et
d'anti démocratique le jeu de
l'opposition c'est de se poser donc moi
si je suis pas si je suis pas d'accord
avec des prises de position du
gouvernement même si elles ont été
votées légalement à l'Assemblée
nationale je continuerai à pas être
d'accord c'est aussi le principe de la
démocratie il y a le contradictoire il y
a des combats politiques qu'on fait donc
tout à fait d'accord il y a toute une
série de réformes depuis le début du qui
ont été mises en place par le par le
gouvernement moi je pense qu'elles ne
sont pas légitimes et et quand bien même
elles sont légales parce que je les
trouve injuste et donc
l'intérêt général et donc je m'y oppose
je respire
le référendum d'initiative partagé il y
a un petit souci au sens où on a fait on
fait croire que mais au final c'est pas
vrai référendum c'est un succès d'Annie
de référendum donc faire croire au
peuple au peuple pour de peuple n'existe
pas
au sens où on fait croire à la rue
qu'elle va pouvoir décider alors qu'au
final le président peut tenir compte ou
pas il me semble me semble-t-il donc ça
peut ça peut au final de ne pas être
pris en compte il faut assembler un
nombre important de personnes
voilà c'est quand même assez énorme et
il y a deux choses que je j'aurais voulu
signaler ici je me souviens de de
Philippe Seguin qui disait que lorsqu'on
reprochait certaines choses aux
institutions peut-être que c'est les
hommes qu'on mettait en cause parce que
au service des institutions donc
peut-être que il y aurait des choses à
changer de son attitude ou sur la façon
de faire la politique aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'on n'en serait pas là c'est
à dire que il y a une
instrumentalisation une triangulation
pour faire simple de de certains
programmes qui font que finalement les
lecteurs et c'est plus très bien on
prend le programme de la droite quand on
est au centre ce qu'elle fait pour être
clair ce qu'elle fait Emmanuel Macron
une certaine façon triangulaire aller
prendre un peu à droite un peu à gauche
avoir un programme le plus large
possible est-ce que c'est véritablement
une manifestation du centre ou est-ce
que c'est une façon purement électorale
ou électoraliste d'essayer de rassembler
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui certains
peuvent dire il n'est pas il n'est pas
mon Président c'est ce que vous essayez
de nous dire parce que finalement vous
avez voté pour lui et je peux me
regarder pas je vous pose pas la
question mais je peux imaginer que vous
avez voté pour lui pour ne pas voter
voilà pour voter donc c'est là c'est là
où on pose c'est là où on pose un
problème parce que c'est pas c'est pas
l'usage du vote donc ça ça pourrait être
un souci et puis autre chose que je
voulais dire c'est ce que des faits plus
sérieusement plus de façon plus je
dirais théorique parce que ce débat là
je trouve qu'il nous emporte peut-être
un peu trop loin c'est du canal Buchanan
et tu Love qui avait finalement dit que
le la moyenne d'avoir la majorité ça ne
suffisait pas il faut plutôt chercher le
médian donc au-delà de la majorité et
avoir quelque chose de plus clair
partagé en deux parties égales
un espace et faire aussi en sorte que
quand on prend une décision elle fasse
moins de de de victimes que de
bénéficiaires faut pas qu'il y ait plus
de victimes que de bénéficiaires de la
de la décision donc si la décision
emporte une certaine légitimité parce
que on va trouver un nombre qui va voter
pour ce qui pourrait être le cas pour le
projet de loi ou finalement le projet de
loi pour le mener par la liotte le 8
juin c'est pas une question de majorité
de l'Assemblée c'est une question
d'avoir une voix de plus que ceux qui
sont contre donc là ça peut se dire ça
peut s'obtenir facilement
ça ne dira pas ça n'ira pas au bout et
il faudrait peut-être mettre en exergue
le fait de dire que socialement
économiquement parlant il faut qu'il y
ait une balance ou avancage et que ce
soit des nouveaux attentats
alors faut savoir comment se place parce
que on peut pas le dire aujourd'hui on
peut le dire sur le son on se projetant
on peut dire de travailler 2 ans de plus
c'est beaucoup alors pour la personne
individu à qui on dit vous allez bosser
deux ans de plus moi j'ai plein de j'ai
plein d'amis universitaires qui disent
tant mieux je voudrais bien bosser 2 ans
de plus parce que j'aurais le droit de
me faire financer des voyages à
l'étranger là on a un prof on peut pas
l'accueillir parce qu'il va avoir 64 ans
et qu'en fac c'est terminé les profs
visiteurs ne peuvent plus venir passer à
64 ans c'est un vrai drame on travaille
avec lui comment on fait bref on va
venir le voir mais il y a cet aspect là
donc il a fait gaultropique et l'aspect
sociopique est-ce que je fais pour moi
pour mes enfants donc si on prend les
considérations intergénérationnelles et
si on considère que les projections qui
sont faites en l'état avec les
hypothèses sur la croissance notamment
et sur l'inflation nous disent que le
système va un déficit accru considérer
que ben je peux être à les filles voilà
un minimum empathique et considéré que
c'est l'avenir de mes enfants qui en
cause donc c'est une bonne réforme de ce
point de vue là peut-être financer la
réforme entre eux
les autres c'est juste un mot justement
ce qui va se passer le 8 juin donc il y
a une promotion de du groupe liotte de
revenir sur la réforme des retraites et
et on voit que bah ça risque d'être
serré là pour le coup
c'est une chance de passer évidemment le
nippe va voter le
procession de lot donc
là c'est l'occasion de faire un un
troisième round une troisième expression
à l'Assemblée nationale sur la sur la
question de la réforme des retraites
maintenant en fait je pense que pour que
les parlementaires et une pression
suffisante pour que ce texte passe il
faut maintenir la mobilisation vous avez
l'Inter syndicale qui appelle deux jours
avant le 11 juin il y a une
représentation donc voilà je pense que
il faut un moment vous dit on arrête
la loi est passée ou alors vous allez
continuer pendant 2 ans pendant 3 ans
pendant 4 ans quand est-ce qu'on
s'arrête il faut il faut savoir
s'arrêter comme un joueur de foot tant
que l'arbitre il a pas sifflé la fin du
match je continue à jouer l'arbitre
c'est le mécontentement pour le
populaire et donc là on a une situation
de crise sociale importante dans notre
pays avec une mobilisation qui est
énorme je pense que la solution de
sortie de crise c'est effectivement de
passer par la voix parlementaire et donc
de d'abroger ce texte de loi à travers
la niche
nationale l'arbitre c'est le peuple
c'est toujours le peuple en démocratie
alors justement on va parler du peuple
parce que le peuple est dans tous ces
états parce que on voit qu'il y a deux
peuples il y a le peuple mécontents dont
vous parlez puis il y a la majorité
silencieuse donc pas de la Major
effective sur 10 c'est cette personne
sur dix sont opposés la réforme des
retraites quand même pour
faire ça puisque
[Musique]
oui c'est assez curieux saisir de parler
au nom du peuple c'est quoi le peuple
c'est une abstraction absolue non oui
par exemple un million et demi de de
gens qui manifestent qui est beaucoup
mais enfin il y a 46 millions de gens
qui votent donc c'est rien si je peux
dire vous voyez ce que je veux dire à
chaque fois
comment on mesure comment on mesure
l'idée qu'on parle au nom du peuple qui
est le peuple ou est-ce qu'il est qui
est son adresse son numéro de téléphone
alors le peuple c'est les citoyens donc
je disais tout à l'heure
quand il se prononce dans les sondages
s'opposent à la réforme des retraites
vous avez à peu près deux tiers des gens
qui sont dans les votes
bon je vous propose un faisceau
d'indices
on peut qu'on peut considérer que une
mobilisation historique depuis les
années 80-90 qui a réuni des millions de
personnes dans pendant une durée de
trois mois enfin c'est sans précédent
quand même traduit un certain
mécontentement populaire qui peut-être
majoritaire
après c'est le rôle des politiques
justement et ben d'être à l'écoute alors
de la rue mais aussi à l'écoute de
globalement quelles sont les attentes
des Français qu'elles sont leurs besoins
et je pense que il y a pas besoin d'être
devant pour considérer que quand on
arrive à 60 ans et qu'on est crevé par
une vie de boulot et bien l'aspiration
majoritaire c'est peut-être de prendre
un temps de repos après une journée de
labeur d'autant plus que les générations
vous pouvez avoir en effet des gens qui
disent mais il y a peut-être auprès tout
une majorité silencieuse peuple
silencieux qu'il a un peu marre des
manifestations du prix de l'essence qui
augmente parce que les raffinerie sont
en grève etc qui voudraient un peu de
calme et un peu de tranquillité il
existe aussi ce peuple là avec ce
raisonnement on peut dire à peu près ce
qu'on veut sur tous les sujets justement
je pense qu'il faudrait aussi de son
temps arrêter de penser que toute
personne est bonne achetée à 60 ans
était à l'article de la mort ça c'est
vous avez une vision qui est quand même
un peu caricaturale de des gens
qui sont au-dessus de la vôtre je suis
désolé tout le monde n'a pas envie de
s'arrêter à 60 ans tout le monde n'est
pas fatigué à 62 tout le monde n'est pas
épuisé à 64 donc voilà donc
rassurez-vous à tout le monde n'a pas
envie de prendre sa retraite à 60 ans
non 62 donc arrêtez de globaliser
dans le public évidemment c'est
différent parce que c'est de l'argent
public donc fixe une limite mais dans le
privé vous pouvez travailler
un avantage
c'est que ça on l'a déjà dit mais elle a
été faite à l'envers il fallait
commencer par parler des carrières
longues de faire des lois sur votre
appareil ensuite arriver parce que quand
vous dites il y a des métiers qui sont
extrêmement difficiles avec
les carrières longues c'est quand même
un peu encadré puis j'espère que là la
CGT va rencontrer Elizabeth borne et
donc on va peut-être avancer sur la
question du travail et quand même une
question fondamentale alors je reviens
au peuple et ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
appelle la mauvaise République
je cite sa phrase
le Conseil constitutionnel ne peut pas
valoir plus que la Constitution qu'il
défend il n'y a pas de bons conseils
constitutionnel aussi longtemps qu'il y
a une mauvaise Constitution à bas la
mauvaise République et alors
on l'a on l'a accusé à ce moment-là
d'être un peu à l'origine mais de
soutenir un peu les vieux c'est vrai
qu'il y a une violence dans l'opinion
votre votre confrère Christophe
Prudhomme qui est
élu à la région on l'a vu l'autre jour
qui dit on a décapité Louis XVI on peut
on peut recommencer avec Macron
c'est limite quand même non même comme
Mélenchon on va montrer à Macron ce que
veut dire le mot insurrection
là j'ai du mal à faire le rapprochement
entre la question de la violence et la
première citation de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sur la mauvaise République je pense que
c'est tout à fait républicain une
mauvaise République est-ce que la
République est divisible heureusement
qu'on peut la révolution heureusement
la Cinquième République et sur son son
mode de fonctionnement est-ce que c'est
normal que une loi passe à l'Assemblée
nationale contre la vie majoritaire
contre la vie des syndicats contre la
vie de l'Assemblée nationale elle-même
et qu'elle passe en force par un outil
qui est le 49-3 donc effectivement on
peut réinterroger notre notre système
nous à la France insoumise
que la Constitution ça veut dire qu'il
respecte la Constitution alors le 49-3
est dans la Constitution alors c'est une
certaine interprétation du Conseil
constitutionnel de le fait qu'il
respecte la Constitution donc je pense
que quand il y a un blocage et un litige
encore une fois il faut imaginer je
pense des institutions démocratiques ou
le peuple peut
ingérer dans la décision politique et
prendre des décisions directement par
exemple par les référendum je reviens je
reviens la question de la violence parce
que dans le discours mélenchon ni ne
cédait pas de vous laisser pas de
domestiquer quoi qu'il en coûte si vous
êtes des insoumis soyez le jusqu'au bout
la lutte continue jusqu'au retrait
jusqu'au retrait de la loi
là aussi il peut y avoir un peu on peut
comprendre ça comme une incitation à
lutte violente
ce discours là vous pouvez l'entendre
dans la bouche de n'importe quel
syndicaliste qui est mobilisé vous
verrez pas le même reproche c'est
Mélenchon parce que
qu'est-ce que vous répondez là quand il
est cotisé veut montrer à Emmanuel
Macron ce que veut dire le mot
insurrection là c'est c'est un truc
signifiant c'est tout à fait ça apaise
le peuple c'est alors parce que moi je
pense que
je pense que c'est tout à fait sain on
démocratie d'appeler les gens à se
mobiliser on peut utiliser des mots
une révolution
c'est Pacifique affirmer franchement
affirmer que les violences sont
manifestations ont un quelconclient avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans la mesure où je
peux vous assurer que les Black Blocs et
compagnies qui cassent des vitrines ils
sont très loin d'être de notre camp
politique de notre mort
admettons mais en attendant répondez
juste à ça est-ce que une insurrection
citez-moi une insurrection qui soit
pacifiste j'en connais pas peut-être
vous avez des réécritures de l'histoire
avec une insurrection des révolutions
le mot insurrection
en fait vous êtes je vous trouve un peu
de mauvaise foi vous savez très bien que
vous savez très bien que la France
insoumise hein elle se présente aux
élections elle joue le jeu démocratique
que elle défend une réforme des
institutions que on est profondément
républicains
parce que le problème de tout ce broua
autour de la fi et violente et pas
républicaine ce discours qu'on entend
depuis quelques mois vis-à-vis de la
gauche parce qu'il y a pas que la fi
dans la dans la nups et vis-à-vis des
syndicats aussi parce que encore une
fois ils disent à peu près la même chose
que nous ils sont dans la même
mobilisation que nous le problème avec
ce discours là c'est que derrière elle
sont beaucoup plus notre histoire est-ce
que c'est pas la même histoire c'est pas
le même danger pour la République et je
pense que ça sert justement votre votre
façon de raisonner à rapprocher ce que
vous appelez les extrêmes à dire qu'au
final l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche d'ailleurs nous qualifier
d'extrême gauche ça me paraît compliqué
la gauche c'est la même chose
le même programme économique justement
de leur traitement quand vous voyez
alors après toutes choses étant égales
parce qu'on sait pas ce qui se passera
dans dans quelques années mais que pour
l'instant c'est plutôt Marine Le Pen qui
profite de la situation
est-ce que ça vous intéresse ce qu'on
est dans le bon la bonne méthode pour
s'opposer alors moi je serais pas
certains de cette interprétation dans
l'ensemble des sondages la nups si elle
est unie est devant Marine Le Pen ça
c'est le premier truc dans l'ensemble
des sondages la nuit
de Le Pen grande gagnante et vous voilà
il y a des sondages donne aussi une
progression de la vitesse
qui donne qu'il s'agit de projection et
il y a une constante dans les sondages
c'est que la nuit pêche politique étant
progression
mais mais mais voilà est-ce que est-ce
que ça vous interpelle pas quand même
de se dire est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de faire là le jeu de l'extrême
droite donc il y a une responsabilité du
gouvernement qui est évidente dans cette
crise démocratique bah c'est pas nous
qui sommes aux affaires
vous vous dites
peut-être qu'on est dans le voilà une
mauvaise qu'on emploie pas la méthode
qu'il faut mais c'est pas nous qui
gagnons au bout c'est vous qui a fermé
que c'est pas nous qui gagnons c'est
affirmation le problème une un des
éléments qui explique la crise dans
lequel nous sommes c'est que elle est
faite en continu en fait depuis 2017 que
on nous répète que chaque élection sera
toujours le même scénario c'est-à-dire
le Front national le deuxième tour avec
la République en marche en face et que
justement la lupesse vient perturber
tout ça c'était une alliance inattendue
on a gagné le premier tour des élections
législatives c'est un combat qui est
long et nous on n'est pas résigné à ce
cet opposition entre d'un côté l'extrême
marcher de l'autre côté l'extrême droite
et qu'on pense que il y a une autre voie
qui est possible c'est celle du progrès
social et de la nups
j'ai pas d'avis sur
personne moi je veux juste la meilleure
stratégie pour gagner à la fin ok merci
merci à tous
on a plein de sujets
voilà parce que la parenthèse est pas
terminée la parenthèse notamment il y a
cette séance du 8 juin à l'assemblée qui
sera très importante la manifestation du
6 évidemment merci à tous et à très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de PAF
[Musique]